kate middleton's spending a lot of time
with children on her official trip to
denmark and she's keeping it real
admitting she's got some major baby
fever that's the duchess of cambridge
visiting a forest kindergarten in
copenhagen on wednesday kate learned all
about their approach to learning and
even spent some time running around with
the little ones
the mom of three even showed off her
wood chopping skills
and it seems all this time with kids has
kate thinking of expanding her own
family the day before while visiting the
children's museum the duchess admitted
being around babies makes her feel a
little broody kate jokingly says of her
hubby quote william always worries about
me meeting under one-year-olds i come
home saying let's have another one i
think the truth is she probably would
she was desperate to have a third i
think william would have been happy to
stop after two kate is one of three
children herself two other siblings so
she's always been keen to have three i
think if she could she'd have a fourth
but there is a practical element i
suppose to all of this we're watching
her now on a very important tour one
that is cementing tires between the uk
and denmark but this isn't the first
time kate's had babies on the brain
last month the couple traveled to
lancashire england to meet with staff
and families at a local hospital at one
point during the visit kate held a baby
girl in her arms compelling william to
make one thing very clear
of course the royal couple has three
children prince george princess
charlotte and prince louis and according
to royal expert katie nichol their
family may be complete of course this is
the queen's platinum jubilee year we're
seeing these important visits carried
out there is a greater workload on the
cambridges these days following the
departure of the sussexes there is more
responsibility for both of them and you
know there is a practical element to all
of this as much as the duchess might
want another baby more is expected of
her and william as they are stepping up
to the plate as more senior royals
alongside charles and camilla so i've no
doubt that she's broody and of course
her work with young children under five
means that she is always with very very
small children and i think that that
probably does make her very broody but
um i think probably three is the magic
number for the cambridges but never say
never